die große atomenergie debatte die bild
angestoßen hat sich jetzt auch die ampel
regierung erreicht können wir uns
angesichts unserer energieabhängigkeit
wirklich leisten ende dieses jahres die
letzten verbleibenden kernkraftwerke in
deutschland abzuschalten weil der
ausstieg aus der atomenergie nicht doch
vielleicht ein großer fehler ein wer
aber noch korrigiert werden kann darüber
muss diskutiert und nun falls auch
gestritten werden denn dieses thema ist
für uns existenziell
bild hat die mega atomenergie debatte
ausgelöst
es ist
außenpolitisch
auch es ist ein weg in deutschland
ist eine debatte für die ich offen bin
denn wir müssen unideologisch über
fragen der energieversorgung sprechen es
geht um bezahlbarkeit und um die
einsparung von co2 emissionen viele
denken da neu wir haben sichere
kernkraftwerke die debatte um
kernenergie nimmt an fahrt auf nicht nur
die regierungsparteien sind sich uneinig
nach einer exklusiven bild umfrage
halten 50 prozent der deutschen es für
sinnvoll zurück zur atomenergie zu gehen
35,4 prozent sind dagegen und 14,5
prozent wollen oder können nichts dazu
sagen dabei gibt es durchaus gute gründe
für atomstrom in deutschland
die drei akw die jetzt noch brauchen
weiter rauchen zulassen würde uns
ungefähr den zehnfachen co2 ersparnis
eines tempolimits 120 bringen allerdings
muss man dazu wissen das funktioniert
nur wenn man stattdessen kohlestrom in
derselben menge aus dem platz haben denn
atomkraftwerke sind so klimafreundlich
wie windkraft laut klima weltrat
verbraucht ein akw gerade mal zwölf
gramm co2 pro erzeugter kilowattstunde
bei der windkraft
bei der photovoltaik sind das auch etwas
über 40 gramm also photovoltaik
sozusagen viermal schmutziger als
kernenergie und windkraft und bei der
kohle geht es dann natürlich
den großen zahlen nennt der weltklimarat
so ungefähr 820 gramm aber bei manchen
kraftwerksblöcken geht das rauch bis
kw es sind so zuverlässig wie ein
kohlekraftwerk denn weder wind ausfall
noch bewölkter himmel kann die
produktion gefährden das was die
kernenergie wirklich auszeichnet dann
hast du tatsächlich auch gesicherte und
planbarer leistung liefert das kann halt
die windkraft noch nicht so lange wir
irgendwas keine speicherten sie haben
die strom entstehungskosten bei
atomkraftwerken liegen bei circa 4 cent
je kilowattstunde
zum vergleich bei windenergie-anlagen
liegt der mittlere wert der strom
entstehungskosten im jahr 2021 bei 6,2
cent die kilowattstunde an land und 9,6
8 cent je kilowattstunde auf dem meer
wenn ausgerechnet die klima regierung
die akw es verschrottet und stattdessen
lieber mehr kohle verbrannt um putins
gas und steinkohle zu ersetzen dann
stimmt was nicht mit dem klima
bekenntnis sicherheits und rechtliche
bedenken der regierung wurden durch
juristische gutachten und kerntechnische
fachleute entkräftet
also muss jetzt nur noch die regierung
sich einig werden wir müssen uni de olo
gisch über fragen der energieversorgung
sprechen solche
zusagen
befindlichkeit einfach nicht mehr
diskutieren und verbrennen lieber kohle
dann müssen sich die grünen wirklich die
frage gefallen lassen sind hier eine
klima oder müssen wir erst auf die
nächste regierung warten bis wir in der
atomenergie debatte mehr klarheit haben